[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants ou le lot que de
bruit mon cher nounours pas trop moi je
ne te sens pas mais au contraire en
nounours va vite voir ce qui se passe
chez nos deux petits amis au long
allons-nous north
bon je veux mais j'aime pas ça a tout de
suite patron open pro piquer ta vilaine
attention aux coups puis j'ai martin
bordeur où l'on rentre vite pour moi
pour gronder poopy elle veut pas dormir
alors jacques martin est morte une homme
bon koch moins vite cet instrument barre
par mon petit nicolas on ne s'en sort
plus aujourd'hui voilà non ta rage en
les offrant vous fait trop de bruit
c'est pour cela qu'elle ne dort pas
poopy nounours c'est parce qu'elle est
capricieuse à l'eau ne pleure plus
mapubi fait tout tout si vous lui
chantier une jolie berceuse
je suis sûr qu'elles seront tournées
rock trafic
oui on en connaît une belle qu'elle nous
toi tu berges tout y est nous chaque
excellente et de violents maux pupy y
los dos do l'enfant dom enfin dormir a
bien vite d'auto photo enfin dormir à
bientôt
dodo l'enfant do la photo vieira bien
dormir à pierreclos
[Musique]
ça y est elles d'un chef nous fait pas
comme lui
une annonce bidon d'or et le cas comme
tata voilà papa pas trop nounours ah oui
je viens vers qui tout et chichi eldar
alors le nom sauve toi vite sinon tu vas
te faire gronder quand on est chez nous
on va se coucher avec pipo de nuit mais
petit ottoman
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eh bien monsieur nounours vous savez
l'heure qu'il est au patro excuses en
bois au coq ou le joli ce père feu doux
tout au fond vos photos nous sommes nous
où elle est très jolie nounours mes
petits amis allez vite vous couchez
embrasser bien fort vos parents et
faites de beaux rêves ball
[Musique]